after 47 days on the road
we're back in washington
we were part of a team of eight dw
journalists
who traveled from california to florida
hoping to understand why
so many in this country see this
election as the most important in their
lifetime
side note we just tested negative for
coronavirus
so enos 7 000 miles on the road how did
this all begin
well we started our road trip on the
west coast
the sky was grey because of the
[Music]
wildfires
[Music]
and we went to visit a family a little
farm
and they had lost everything
we got married here on the farm actually
just um
under that oak tree over there and
you know so not not having that not
having pictures of our friends
that's um that's hard so while we were
in california actually trump made a
surprise visit to california because he
hadn't really been talking about
the wildfires until then
it seemed that he wanted to show people
in california that he actually cared
about it
[Applause]
it was really fascinating how excited
they were
oh my god girl we got to get another
four more okay
another four more and keep america great
but it wasn't just trump supporters who
showed up it was also there were
protests there
[Music]
at a certain point there was rumors
going around that an accident happened
somebody had driven their car into
protesters
what seemed kind of crazy to me is that
this only made the local news
that cars driving into protesters has
become so commonplace in this country
that it doesn't even resonate anymore
do you guys need anything right now do
you need anything okay
so then we left california and we went
to mormon country
[Music]
right to utah i mean many people know it
because it's stunningly beautiful these
red rocks these arches
but it's also mormon country
and we met this woman she showed us her
church
she really walked us through her fears
so if
joe biden and kamilah harris would
become president and vice president what
would this mean for your country
i think that it would mean a big
downfall
we would have a civil war again there
would be a civil war here
i believe if they were to become because
there's a lot of americans that don't
want to be
a new world order they don't want to be
part of the new world order
she's really really preparing for the
worst
this is just my basic survival stuff i
got a raincoat
i got some teepees some stuff to help
keep me
warm and the mormons obviously
are preppers in that regard anyhow
they're always prepared you know to be
ready to go
but now with this election coming and
with the fear that this country might
turn into chaos
they're getting extra prepared in there
obviously more of them
than usual are getting weapons as well
that's my gun
and i wouldn't be able to hurt nobody
with it i wouldn't i'd be like
stay away don't make me hurt myself
because i could because i can't hurt
people but i wouldn't want to hurt
myself either so
but yeah so it's i don't i don't even
yeah it's not loaded
bullets are somewhere in here
i'd have to hit somebody with it before
i'd even get hurt with that shoot him so
so immigration is one of the most
important topic in this election so you
have
those who are afraid that more
immigrants would take their jobs away
they want donald trump to build this
wall
they want him to protect their jobs and
then you have the others
they think america the united states are
or is
rich enough really to support those in
need
and that's what we experience everywhere
we went to colorado pueblo colorado and
there we met
a man from west africa who's just
waiting to
be deported
[Music]
in some ways i feel like i'm an outsider
even though i've been here for 20 years
you know i'm i've assimilated to the
culture language
customs you name it but however because
there isn't that
green card or citizenship kind of
passport that says
i am an american i feel like i'm outside
i'm
other instead of being an american so
normally you would assume that trump
supporters don't take care of an
african refugee from west africa without
any legal papers but they did
amen amen you know he's our adopted son
basically and we
what what would how would we feel if
that happened to brandon or sean
our physiologic sons
and if you want to see that report by
our colleague oliver salat you can find
the link
in the description under this video
so this uh election campaign is also
shaped by images of
burning houses and burning cars
kenosha is one of those places
[Music]
so we drove there just a month after the
riots have happened
[Music]
it was pretty moving to see these these
burned cars and to imagine
what this place went through
[Music]
trump points to that town and says
look what happens when you have
democrats in charge and then
democrats point to that town and they
say yes
houses burned and cars burned and there
was a lot of destruction from black
lives matter protesters and from
antifa but two people died there
and the two people who died there were
protesters
allegedly killed by a young man with a
rifle
from the right wing
so you can really see how people
can take a city like kenosha and turn it
into two different stories
i think what we experienced really from
this side to the other side is that
there's hardly any
place where people come together and
share their arguments and i think
kenosha would be a good place
so well and the election really started
at this point in ohio
[Music]
we went there to the little town of
springfield
which was really fairly rich some years
ago but now is really decimated because
of the industrial changes
and which voted for donald trump in
2016.
and we talked to the head of the
democratic local democratic party there
and asked him you know why things have
changed and what he expects
what they were hearing and what actually
has happened is two different things
they were hearing donald trump is going
to do all these magnificent things he's
going to take care of you
he's going to help the american workers
and that just that promise has not been
kept
you never know until the ballots are
counting
what i hope i hope joe biden becomes
our next president that's what i would
hope
but there's one voting bloc in the
united states that really doesn't seem
like it's going to change its mind
and that is why we went to indiana right
we went there to meet
evangelicals it's up to 25 percent
of those americans who vote
and their main issue is abortion they're
anti-abortion
that's the topic they kind of come
together
behind they don't really care so much
about donald trump's personal life
they don't like it that he cusses and
swears
but they say for then he is the right
president
because he is fighting with them against
abortion
there's a lot about donald trump that i
don't like that i don't agree with
but in the areas that he does promote
truth and justice i pray that god would
bless his administration
but this of course only applies to white
evangelicals
because if you look at black
evangelicals the picture is completely
different and that's why we went down
south
to georgia to talk to black voters right
that's when early voting began in
georgia
[Music]
we talked to many people who explained
to us how difficult it is
in this year's election to find places
to vote
especially for african americans we saw
massive lines at some of these polling
places in georgia on the first day
some people waited up to 12 hours to
cast their ballot
so this was early voting people who were
going there weeks ahead of the election
one thing that really moved me was this
moment when a woman
who had been standing in line for hours
it was really hot
she collapsed
all of a sudden she gets up and a poll
worker escorted her
into the building she refused to go
home but she wanted to vote and he said
well you've waited long enough i'm going
to take you inside
[Music]
well many say this is the most important
election in their lifetime and i
i agree i mean i was really stunned
about the patience of the people i mean
they
stood there in the rain and the heat
that shows you how important this year's
election is and how much it means for
many many americans to be able
to vote
[Music]
then we kind of went off to another
planet to florida
[Music]
this is the most important swing state
if
donald trump doesn't win florida he
probably has lost the elections
so uh we went to this little place
kamala harris the vice presidential
candidate from the democrats were
holding a small event
and outside this place there were trump
supporters
i uh try to talk to them and
and and try to understand why they hate
kamala harris so much hi ma'am
camila harris is right there what would
you tell her if you would be able to
speak with her
she's a communist she's garbage she's
locked so many black people up
she's actually a monster just like biden
she's a very ignorant woman and she's
but i have to say as a reporter
i kind of failed
[Music]
we said we were on the road to the white
house but you can't get that close to
the white house anymore
yeah this fence is fairly new they just
put it up for election night so
i think that pretty much tells the story
of this this united states of america
you